معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمي نجوان ماذا عن الوضع
ومستجداته في
الصوره هنا في منطقه غلاف غزه لا يتوقف
القسف عبد القادر على مواقع مختلفه في هذه
المناطق التي نرصدها تحديدا شرق قطاع غزه
لكن اللافت هو اننا لا نتمكن من رصد اثار
هذا القذف على مقربه من الشريط
الحدودي بمعنى ان القصف من هذه المناطق
نعم عنيف جدا لكنه من الواضح يستهدف مواقع
الى الغرب من هذه المناطق المحاذيه للحدود
الشرقيه مع قطاع غزه طيله الوقت كنا عندما
نسمع مثل هذا القصف العنيف مباشره نرى على
طول خط الشريط الحدودي المحاذي تماما
لمنطقه غلاف غزه اثار هذا القصف المدفعي
لكن ايه نكاد لا نرى اثار هذا القصف
المتواصل منذ اكثر من ساعه على مناطق في
المناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه ولكن ايضا
قصف يستهدف مناطق في مخيمات الوسط وهذا
يعني ان القصف يستهدف مواقع الى العمق
اكثر من الحدود الشرقيه
اي مثال هنا ما يقابلنا هو حي الشجاعيه
فمن الواضح ان القصف من هذه المناطق
يطال احياء الى الغرب من منطقه الشجاعيه
في داخل مدينه غزه كحي الدرج وايضا حي
التفاح لكن ايضا في مناطق الى الغرب من
منطقه جحر الديك في المغرا وفي المخيمات
الوسطى نسمع دوي انفجارات عنيفه طيله
الوقت جراء هذا القصف ويبدو بانها تقع الى
الغرب اكثر من منطقه مخيم البريج بمعنى ان
هذا القصف نعم متواصل صل لكنه يستهدف
مناطق غربيه اكثر من المواقع التي تقع
مباشره على الحدود المتاخمه لغلاف غزه هذا
القصف يرافقه ايضا تحليق متواصل للطيارات
او مروحيات الاباتشي عفوا وايضا تحليق
لمسيرات عسكريه نراها بين الحين والاخر
وهناك طله الوقت ايضا نلمح من هنا تحركات
لاليات عسكريه على طول الشريط الحدودي
المحاذي المناطق الشرقيه والاحياء الشرقيه
لمدينه غزه صباح هذا اليوم اعلن المتحدث
العسكري الاسرائيلي في بيانه الصباحي عن
اخر عملياته في غزه وقال بان الجيش خلال
ال 24 ساعه الاخيره استهدف ما لا يقل عن
100 هدف وصفها بطبيعه الحال مقرات قياده
ومنشات ومواقع عسكريه وبنى تابعه لحركات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحديدا لحركه حماس
لكنه بطبيعه الحال يتح حدث عن تركيز
العمليات العسكريه في منطقه خان يونس في
منطقه الجنوب الذي كان قد اعلن الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي بان المرحله مرحله
الحرب قص عنيف اخر اذا تماما كما كنا
نتحدث هذا قصف هذا هو القصف المدفعي يتم
اطلاقه من مواقع قريبه من حيث نتواجد لكن
كما ذكرت يعني وفقا لمشاهدت هذا اليوم
نحاول ان نرصد اثار هذا القص اثار الدخان
التي عاده تنبعث مباشره بعد عمليات القصف
الا اننا لا نستطيع ان نشاهدها وهذا يدل
على ان هذا القصف يطال مناطق او يستهدف
مناطق بعينها لكن تقع الى الغرب من هذه
المناطق الشرقيه
اي بالعاده عمليات القصف بالمدفعيه تطال
من هنا من هذه المواقع المناطق المحاذيه
للشريط الحدودي على طول الشريط الحدودي من
جهه الشرق لقطاع غزه لكن من الواضح انه
هذا اليوم يستهدف مواقع في مناطق واحياء
غربيه اكثر من الشريط الحدودي اذا
العمليات متواصله والتركيز وفقا للناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي للعمليات البريه
تحديدا في منطقه خان يونس والجنوب بهدف
التقدم وحسم المعركه كما يقول كما حدث في
المناطق الشماليه عبد القادر من غلاف غزه
مراسلا الجزيره نجوان سمري شكرا جزيلا لك